>>> GET BACK!
I TOLD YOU ALL TO GET BACK!
>> LET HER THROUGH, SHE'S THE
NEGOTIATOR.
>> THANKS.
WHAT'S THE SITUATION?
>> GOT A GUY UP ON THE ROOF,
ARMED, ONE HOSTAGE.
THIS COULD GO SOUTH AT ANY
SECOND.
>> LET'S GET STARTED.
OH.
BY THE WAY, I HOPE YOU DON'T
MIND BUT I ATE ALL THOSE GUMMY
BEARS YOU HAD IN YOUR CAR.
>> WAIT.
WHAT GUMMY BEARS?
>> THOSE NEON COLORED GUMMY
BEARS, THE ONES THAT KIND OF
SMELL BAD, THE STICKY ONES, THE
ONES YOU HAD HID IN THE BAG THAT
SAID "EVIDENCE."
>> OH, GOSH.
>> ALL RIGHT, RYAN.
THIS IS DETECTIVE WILLIAMS.
>> JUST GIVE ME WHAT I WANT OR
THIS GUY GOES SPLAT!
>> ALL RIGHT, RYAN, I NEED YOU
TO CALM DOWN, OKAY?
HERE IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO.
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS --
-- OH.
>> WILLIAMS?
YOU OKAY?
>> OH --
♪ I'M A WEED GUMMY
YES I'M A WEED GUMMY ♪
♪ I'MA I'MA I'MA
I'M A WEED GUMMY
YES I'M A WEED GUMMY ♪
>> WILLIAMS?
TRY NOT TO MOVE.
>> UH-HUH?
♪ YOU SHOULD NOT
HAVE EATEN ME ♪
♪ YES I'M A WEED GUMMY
I'MA I'MA I'MA ♪
♪ I'M GOING TO TELL
YOUR FAMILY ♪
♪ I'M A WEED GUMMY AND
YOU'LL BE HIGH FOREVER ♪
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
>> THINK I DIED.
PRETTY SURE I DIED.
I'M DEFINITELY DEAD.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
HEY, DON'T FREAK OUT.
BUT NOW THERE'S TWO OF THEM.
>> TWO OF WHAT?
♪ WE ARE WEED GUMMYS
YES WE ARE WEED GUMMYS ♪
♪ I'MA I'MA I'MA
THERE'S A RACE OF ♪
♪ VOLCANO PEOPLE
THEY'RE UNDERGROUND ♪
♪ AND CONSIST OF LAVA ♪
♪ WE NEED TO FIND THEM
THEY HAVE THE ANSWERS ♪
♪ NOW SAY HELLO
TO MARGE SIMPSON ♪
>> MARGE SIMPSON, YOU'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE UP THERE.
>> OH HOMIE, I'M NOT MARGE, I'M
THE DEVIL AND YOU'RE MY GREATEST
CREATION.
>> GRACIAS.
BUENOS DIAS!
>> WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> DO YOU GUYS WANT TO TAKE LIKE
A 10-MINUTE BREAK?
>> WILLIAMS.
ARE YOU OKAY?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
A SERIOUS QUESTION, THOUGH.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE SUN?
♪ NOTHING'S WRONG
WITH THE SUN
HE JUST GOT OLDER ♪
♪ JUST HAD A PUPPY'S BABY
IT'S ALL GROWN UP NOW ♪
♪ LOOK INTO HIS
DEAD DOG EYES ♪
>> WHOA!
♪ MY MORTAL ENEMY
IS THE MOON ♪
>> THIS IS ALL KIND OF STARTING
TO FREAK ME OUT.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU GUYS WIN.
JUST GET ME OUT OF HERE.
>> OH MY GOD, WILLIAMS, YOU DID
IT.
WILLIAMS?
♪ I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU FIXED IT ♪
♪ YES WE ARE WEED GUMMYS
I'MA I'MA I'MA ♪
♪ YOU'RE GOING TO GET
A PROMOTION ♪
♪ EVERYTHING IS BETTER NOW
WE ARE GOING TO ♪
>> WHAT IS SHE DOING?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
♪ I'MA I'MA I'MA ♪♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]